Bojack Wow Jesus you look shitty have
you been eating your guilt this whole
time I have cancer and hello who's this
stunning creature and what string of bad
decisions has placed you in bojack's
orbit this is Diane
she's writing a book about me yeah is
your book called portrait of an asshole
I get it's funny because he ruined my
life I joke it's what I do please come
in you're letting out all the cancer
[Laughter]
[Music]
we've got two sacks of Kardashian swag
and the fuzz on our heels drive the
goddamn car hey herb is that your
Vitamix
Bojack has one too I wonder if you guys
have strong opinions about it one way or
the other the stupid thing was like 600
mind a grand total of zero times I got
it a month before I was diagnosed with
cancer I don't give a about being
healthy anymore I don't even have cancer
and I don't use it so who's it for
exactly what is so great about liquids
every article I read now is juice this
and juice that you know why juice
controls the media thing go any faster
you're doing a great job
Henze stop talking to him why nice
remember the number one rule of the
celebrity stealing Club no falling in
love that's your rule for every club
it's a good rule whoa whoa guys I'm
sensing a lot of hostility here maybe we
should take our masks off and actually
talk do you want me to take my mask off
fine happy I took my mask off did you
because I think you're still wearing
masks
[Music]